we are indeed with the leader in the
ladies section Jennifer you after
another crucial Victory Jennifer
congratulations a big one with the black
pieces against one of your main
competitors how do you feel right now
um yeah I mean I'm pretty happy with the
result uh going to this game like I
didn't really know what to play against
her
um played the petrol so it's kind of
drawish for a while but you know I was
also like I really wanted to win this
game like it was a strange decision
because I was trying to just get like a
playable position so that I could win
but
um I mean I guess it ended up working
out but did you feel uh that you
surprised her with this Petrov decision
I think I did
um because she's thought for a while
here before playing D4 but
um I I thought like she was gonna expect
it because I have played this quite a
few times in the past but
um I have been playing really random
openings this tournament so it probably
makes it harder Bishop D3 D5 and you
entered this main line with the bishopon
D6 and she decided to go for Knight C3
instead of C4
did you know anything about the position
were you still in your book at this
point
uh no I
for some reason 1967 just completely
like I was like oh did not expect 1967.
already here Knight Texas yeah even
though it's like definitely very popular
um because I I thought she was gonna
play like
um I think she was in a castle or
something but uh I mean I knew a little
bit about this position because I played
this for a few years so I know it's like
some ideas but um so I wasn't like
afraid of going into this and she took
on D7 and I think this was quite
critical at this point F5 C4 how did you
assess the position right now I think
you spent quite a long time uh playing
this move Queen to F6 yeah
um my time usage here was not that great
um but I just could not decide because
there was a few ideas I could do here
um I could also take on C4 and canadi I
just didn't like that as much I think
I don't know what the valuation was I
think it should be okay yeah I thought
it was like around that quality yeah
yeah but I just thought this was
um less of a practical chance because
thing is I know I'm black but I you know
I don't like drawing I like I like doing
so
um I thought like that would just be
more passive positions so I thought
Queen F6 was just like a better chance
because here okay so I assume she was
also trying to beat me which is also
like why I did this open because
otherwise I think like if you want you
could play Bishop G5
um trade the Queens off and then it
should be like a pretty simple like
um end game this one yeah and then you
can move the bishop back and three
Bishop yeah so I I mean I don't know
it's you can definitely play on for a
while but I think it's like a very
simple compared to the game so that's
why I was like really happy see Bishop
D3 which I kind of expected to because
it also like complicates the position
more
um and this move came on board
H4 no I was like H4 at first I was like
what is this
um because it seems so impractical
because like now your Queen's stuck on
H5 but Bishop G5 is actually kind of a
problem
um in a lot of moves so I was like oh
this move H4 I can't believe it works
but does
so you play Bishop D5 Bishop P3 C6 and
finally she got her Bishop G5
at the only moment that she could have I
think this was another critical moment
it felt like she was getting closer and
closer to making a draw
but then you ladies got into this end
game how did you assess this one at this
point I mean I thought this was should
be a draw but um it's
I don't know like what is the correct is
it just F3 Rook B4 I think King G1 was
fine okay and go all the way to here and
now just G3 was it feels like a bad
mistake yeah that's the thing like here
I was like already accepting this might
be a draw but the thing is she still has
to defend it
um and that's like it's really tricky
here because it looks like G3 should be
easily drawn but like it just I get
there's like six one at some point like
not like six one it's just kind of like
what happened in the game where it's
like and I think this was the critical
move you found this move King to H4
because if you go F3 first and King G3
if you go G4 first then root to B4 seems
to equalize the position yeah um King to
H4 and
at this point you guys were repeating
moves and then she allowed you to go G4
what was your plan after King to G2
um work day three Rook D3 yes and then
if she takes now you go F3 it's like
transposes too like
um because before she could have taken
on B70 would have been the same thing
but she played
um at what point uh
yeah right here when I play Teenage four
it's the same thing
got it yeah but you can take but now you
go F3 yeah so rugby four was knife moved
by her but
um now Rook before doesn't work because
because
I got like confused it I was like it
looks like something weird is not going
on
so I think at this point oh never mind
so Rook to D7 King to G2 was the
question but now you go to D3 yeah and
then yeah and then now your rook's still
stuck on B4 and if you go King H2 oh now
you can go here right and then King H3
was that it
how are you planning on making progress
oh here I think I was just gonna go like
I could oh maybe this this and just wait
yeah I think that no no now you can take
on B7 the problem is the King has to be
on H4
um
I think uh Teenage two I was gonna do oh
I could do G4 right
King H2 oh no no G4 is not good they're
gonna
maybe B5 here yeah wait B5 not B6
but no this is because you the pawn has
to be on F3
where's the wind guys you're doing a
great job Christian We're Not Gonna
I looked at this for sure
um
it says 57 King H2 let's try to figure
out maybe Rook to F7 here
and now King to G4
yeah you cannot wait anymore yeah so she
has to do something you have to go here
and now we have three yeah
yeah there we go we found it anyway very
nice conversion after that she did not
play this uh important victory for you
you're going into tomorrow's match
against Irina crush with a half point
lead how are you going to approach that
one
well I think I'm gonna just kind of
approach it normally the thing is I I
always think I was kind of joking around
a few days ago and I was like I really
like playing like must win kind of
situations because I always have a lot
of fun playing those I don't know I just
like to play Under Pressure so I was
like maybe I should just treat every
single game like that yeah situation
um I mean obviously you know if I don't
have to go crazy if it's like very drawn
but I think you know I'm gonna just play
normally like in that way
um yeah this is also I think the last
time I played this tournament I also had
the same situation I was like half Point
late second to last round so hopefully
we have the same result but we'll see
guys any questions congratulations
you're playing playing great somehow you
do well matching up with Arena I was
really surprised in your head to head
you have two wins in one row what is it
about your games in the past with Arena
that's benefited you
um
I think back on the last few times we
play
um
are maybe it was it's because of our
Styles but um I think I'm also always
black every single time we play like I
think every single time so this will be
interesting
um because I don't maybe I played her
once this way or something like that
tomorrow you're going to be black again
I'm black again I think tomorrow right
tomorrow
don't mess her up she's she's doing
great without your help
our producer is right
so but
um
so I think I've always kind of played
the game on like her terms a little bit
because she's kind of like choosing kind
of positions we're heading to so it'd be
interesting to see what I do with the
way
all right well we'll be watching yes the
whole world will be watching actually uh
nice good luck Jim
great job and we have a